but it's not just their fault this we
live
in a sort of vacuous culture a vapid
culture
we all participate in it every last one
of us
i saw this yesterday i don't know if
you've been following on instagram
there's this trend that has taken over
instagram many of my dearest friends are
doing it so i'm not on a poke too sharp
fun here
women are are taking
hot black and white selfies of
themselves i guess most selfies are of
yourself
they're taking these selfie photos and
then they're uploading it to instagram
and they're saying challenge accepted
and so all the all the women on
instagram were doing this i thought
oh it's another one of these social
media challenge things okay
what's the challenge and so i'm looking
and i
i found out the challenge is to upload a
hot
selfie that is it's not
that's not part of the challenge or the
medium of the challenge
that's the whole challenge is to get
women
on an app that exists solely for women
to put up hot pictures of themselves
the challenge is for women to put up hot
pictures of themselves
there's not even a nominal social
justice tie-in you know
most of these challenges there's like at
least a little hook it's like yeah
upload a hot selfie and that and then
you'll cure
a disease you know upload a hot selfie
to stop polio and you're like well i
don't really see the connection between
those two things but
at least but this one it's not even that
it's just just vanity
that's all it is it's just women
uploading photos of themselves
and saying i'm beautiful i'm strong and
i nominate and then you name all these
other women that you
you also suggest should upload hot
photos of themselves
and then the other women they post the
photos and they say thank you for
nominating me
thank you for challenging i feel so
challenged
so anyway the other night i put up one
of myself and i don't know frankly i
thought it was
it was one of the more scintillating
challenging things i've ever done i feel
really lifted up and empowered also is
it
is it empowering to upload a hot selfie
for other people to gawk over is that
that that is many things but i'm not
convinced
that that is empowering what's funny now
they're trying to add
a a kind of social justice element to it
so it's so all these women are uploading
the photos just for themselves just to
say like i'm beautiful you're strong you
go girl
we don't we don't need anybody's
attention also look at my hot pictures
so that's the thing that everyone's
doing now
then some women in turkey got upset
because apparently a few weeks ago there
was a campaign in turkey to upload black
and white photos to stop women from
being killed or something to that effect
has nothing to do with what the women
in america are doing and they're getting
angry because they feel like it's being
taken over
and this reminds me of the black square
you remember all these mostly white
liberals were uploading the black
squares during black lives matter
and they were doing it to stand in
solidarity with blm and then the blm
people got angry because it was messing
up their hashtag or something right it's
just
you can't you can't win for a losing
first of all
and especially in the case of the black
and white photo what are we what's the
point
the point is is uh vanity and
and we all do it i'm not even exempting
myself i mean i don't i don't do it when
it comes to posting hot selfies but
we all do it in some ways we all indulge
this vanity in this culture
that's what that whole hearing was
yesterday
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts